oh my
God thank you I am so excited you're
here in person this time yeah it's
exciting that was a great song by the
way thank you it's very different from
the original but you knock it
out you knock it out of the par I love
that you're just talking to me in person
this time I was over Zoom last time and
I was so excited have you and I was like
damn that's not the same yeah it was not
the same yeah but you're in New York
City right now doing a show so I live
here now so what are like your places I
should go oh well what I love to do when
I come to New York if I get a chance I
bike ride but down done that yet down
the wests side highway there's a bike
path and you can go on a really nice day
you know it's it's starting to get cold
now New York I must admit but it it you
you can ride from the George Washington
Bridge all the way down the battery Park
I my friend Deb has told me this I know
I want to do amazing it's an amazing
trip you know you go with a couple of
friends or whatever and uh you could
stop along the way you go stop you stop
a little lunch or something and know I'm
this food involves almost everything I
do yeah yeah me too yeah we would make
great friends um I heard that you worked
in a beauty parlor when you were younger
true well my sister my sister Angie my
oldest sister was a beautician and she
that's she did see when I was a kid in
Jersey I worked all the time from the
time I was like uh 13 14 12 13 years old
I worked in a at the church selling soda
at bingo night right that was mying like
a Friday night yeah that was my big
thing and then the next job I had
basically when I got my working papers
where putting little kids on the rides
like down at the I'm from Asbury Park
New Jersey yeah yeah yeah you know you
have the like the little kitties who
come and they'd have the like the little
little fire engine you know they have
the the little truck or the car and you
and you put them on you stick the little
strap across you go ring the bell ring
the bell you know honk the horn and they
go around a circle they didn't really
drive you know yeah did you ever have
the kids that were terrified but their
parents were like smile baby yeah yeah
oh yeah and well it was way before all
the all the uh little cell phones and
stuff so we didn't have to have we had
you know disposable cameras Oh my God I
lived with them I remember when they
came out with the ones that went
underwater and I was like was blow that
was like amaz that one yeah and I never
took good pictures neither always like
even like they're like this was taken on
an iPhone you see those Billboards I'm
like not on mine not on my phone yeah I
don't take good pictures my sister I was
saying she had a beauty po so when I I
did things like I was a gardener I
worked you know did did things shovel
snow and winter I worked for a guy who
had a a gardening business in the summer
and she said what are you going to do
you know now you out High School you you
know and I wasn't going to go to college
and she said well why don't you come to
work for me I got the beauty p and I
said Angie what do I look like a
petition you what am I going to do she
said so I'm going to send you to school
so I said okay so all summer she prepped
me for this uh school started in
September in in asor it's called the
Wilford ACA beauty academy or something
like that and I was dragging my feet
like crazy I was going a Andrew I don't
know if this is going to work out you
know this is like I I know if I'm she's
now come on and then Aunt so and so know
we would do pin curls and com outs and
teasing and you know more about hair
than I do I I you know permanent waves
colar did all this stuff and then I go
so I go to school first day I go to
school she bought me the whole thing you
had the you had this this the white SM
and the she had all the tools in the kit
and I said oh God and I don't know if
I'm going to be able to do this and I
walk up these stairs and really hesitant
and I open the door and in this big room
with all these stations with with little
wig blocks and stuff all around behind
was a coffee bar uh and there were 35
women in there all my age and knew you
were going then I went
what what the hell and I I went
immediately I didn't go in I went
downstairs and was pay phones then you
know I went down call Angie I say Angie
I owe you for the rest
of I knew you were going to go you're
going to walk in and tell those women
yeah I was like I I it was seriously
like dying and going to heaven and it
was a great I the you know and then
working was good too but the the study
working was really the study
yeah oh my God I love you so much okay I
heard in New York too that you because
y'all made so many movies together that
I love um you and Michael Douglas but I
didn't know you were roommates in New
York yeah yeah well we met in
Connecticut at in
1960 something like four or five at at
the Eugene O'Neal Foundation it's a it's
a place where they they they they read
plays for young uh authors writers you
know what and then they'd stag them and
things I was going through the the it
was in Connecticut it was beautiful
place and Michael was there and
everybody was there he was a student at
the time at UCSB so uh there was a they
were building a Amphitheater and it was
had these big you know they were going
to put U you know so everybody's
somebody knew what they were doing with
the cinder blocks and everything but all
the actors were helping out we were out
there you know lugging things put
digging ditches stuff like that wow and
and and middle of the day it was really
hot somebody said well who wants to go
on a beer run so I immediately raised my
hand Michael raised his yeah I'll go
we'll go and he had a motorcycle so I
said like well we'll go you you'll
you'll ride and I'll I'll sit on the
back and and we took five steps away
from the everybody else and we both had
hair it was hippie days right it was a
hippie we had hair down here right and
uh first thing he said to me he says you
smoke pot and I said
y so the beer didn't show up for two
hours I
mean but we got we got to see the
countryside and we we toed around
looking at all the you know the little
sojourn here and there oh my God
everybody's wanting a beer and y'all are
toing it up we to yeah I love it we're
[Music]
[Applause]
baking thank you guys yall have a great
night I'm going
home